[Musique]
on se rend compte depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire qui est des
nouveaux visages qui clairement incarne
d'un les nouvelles personnes les
nouveaux profils de la précarité que ce
soit des jeunes des étudiants des
commerçants des artisans des extras des
intermittents multi des salariés
fragilisés par le chômage partiel donc
toute cette nouvelle catégorie de la
population
c'est très dur aussi pour eux de pousser
la porte d'une association pour aller
demander de l'aide alimentaire ou de
l'aide tout court et conséquences de
cette crise sanitaire elle est
économique mais également sociales au
printemps dernier le gouvernement dans
l'urgence a développé une enveloppe
conséquente pour aider les associations
caritatives mais c'était vraiment une
action qui était ponctuelle qui était
d'urgence on est six mois après le
déblocage de ces fonds les associations
sont partis au point zéro et le nombre
de personnes en situation précaire ne
fait qu'augmenter dans mon département
des alpes-maritimes plus de 18 %
d'inscrits au chômage plus de 18 % de
bénéficiaires est urss a donc il faut
absolument agir de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens sont maintenant touchés par
cette pauvreté alors au sein du groupe
l'est républicain au sénat on a fait de
nombreuses propositions sur la précarité
comme la mise en place d'un contrat
urgence jeunes avec zéro charge
en échange d'activités essentielles
pendant la crise qu vide on a souhaité
aussi renforcer le bouclier familière
donnant un coup de pouce aux allocations
familiales en les augmentant et en
allant au delà du coup préau des vingt
ans et propose également d'augmenter la
déduction fiscale dont bénéficient les
associations qui luttent contre la
pauvreté je crois que la précarité
aujourd'hui cette grande fragilité doit
être prise au sérieux et doit vraiment
sortir du clivage politique doit devenir
maintenant une priorité numéro un pour
le gouvernement
[Musique]